شكرا لي زميل ابراهيم بدر اهلا بكم
مشاهدينا الى ساعه اخباريه جديده نخصص
معظمها لتغطيه المشهد بالسودان والبدايه
بالعناوين
تجدد الاشتباكات في الخرطوم قبل انتهاء
الهدنه والولايه تعلن عن عطله لاجل غير
مسمى
حمدوك يحذر من تحول مواجهات الجيش والدعم
السريع الى حرب اهليه وكابوس عالمي
الهلال الاحمر السوداني يؤكد ان الامكانات
داخل المستشفيات محدوده ويطالب بمساعدات
في ساعتنا الخبريه ايضا
القوات الروسيه تقصف مركز تحكم بالطائرات
المسيره الاوكرانيه قرب خرسون
[موسيقى]
ليله هادئه عاشتها الخرطوم على عكس
الليالي السابقه قبل ساعات من انتهاء هدنه
هشه يامل السودانيون بالاعلان عن تمديدها
لكن الاشتباكات تجددت صباح اليوم وصدرت
تحذيرات من محدوديه الامكانات داخل
المستشفيات كما صدرت مطالبات بمساعدات
عاجله لتجنب كارثه انسانيه
[موسيقى]
ومع دخول المعارك بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع اسبوعها الثالث وبعد ليله هادئه
شهيدتها الخرطوم تجددت الاشتباكات صباح
اليوم حيث تشهد المهندسين والصالحه
اشتباكات بالاسلحه الخفيفه والثقيله وقصف
بالطيران وبحسب شهود عيان من منطقه
الحلفايه شمال مدينه الخرطوم بحري بدا
الجيش في نشر وحداته والقيام بعمليات
تمشيط بعد معارك عنيفه شهدتها امس هذا
وتجدد سماع دوي انفجارات واصوات اطلاق
النار في محيط القياده العامه للجيش
السودان المركزي
الطابق
الاخير
الله يسترنا طبعا بيننا
يعني لو وقع الاخير في لبنان خلاص
هذا هو اعلنت ولايه الخرطوم السودانيه عن
عطله الى اجل غير مسمى ابتداء من اليوم
الاحد وذلك بسبب الظروف الامنيه التي
تعيشها البلاد ولا تشمل العطله غرف اداره
الازمه والمرافق الخدميه الحيويه
وفي سياق متصل الاعلان طويله القضارف ونهر
النيل في السودان حاله الطوارئ لمواجهه
تداعيات الاشتباكات الجاريه حاليا في
البلاد حيث امر والي القضارف باعلان حاله
الطوارئ لمده شهر مؤكدا ان من يخالف
الاوامر يعرض نفسه للغرامه او السجن هذا
واعلن والي نهر النيل عن حاله الطوارئ
بالولايه ووجه الجهات المختصه بتنفيذ
الامر وفق وسائل اعلام محليه
اما في ولايه غرب دارفور فقد اعلن الجيش
السوداني في بيان ان لجنه امن الولايه
نجحت بالحد من التوتر القبلي وان شرطه
الاحتياطي تفتح تدريجيا مناطق في جنوب
الخرطوم الجيش السوداني اشار في بيانه الى
ان الموقف العملياتي مستقر في جميع
المناطق العسكريه بالبلاد واكد استمرار
بعض الدول اجلاء رعاياها من الخرطوم
وبورتسوتان
ومن لندن ينضم الينا الكاتب الصحفي خالد
الاعسر وايضا ينضم الينا من ولايه
مريلاند الامريكيه الدكتور صلاح البشير
الباحث السياسي مرحبا بكم معي في هذه
الساعه اريد فقط ان اشير الى الاخبار
العاجله اسفل الشاشه لبيان الجيش السوداني
قال بانه دمر ارتالا للدعم السريع في
مناطق جنوب الزريبه والمويلح وفتاشه وقال
بانه مستمر في تهيئه الظروف لعوده الشرطه
تدريجيا الى الشوارع وقال بان مجموعات
الدعم السريع حولت مستشفى شرق النيل الى
تكنه عسكريه الجيش اضاف ايضا بان عمليات
اجلال رعايه الدول الاجنبيه ستتواصل من
قاعده وادي سيدنا
كذلك ايضا اضاف الجيش السوداني بانه مستمر
في رصد تحركات الدعم السريع
وسيتصدى لها في كل الولايات تبدا معك سيد
خالد كيف تعلق على هذا البيان اولا للجيش
السوداني
تحيه لك ولمشاهديكم الكرام وضيفك العزيز
البيانات التي يصدرت جيش السوداني تبين
سير العمليات على الارض
والحديث عن الارتال هو مسنود بشواهد كثيره
وفيديوهات ان هناك في الفترات الماضيه
محاولات لاختراق الهدن بجلب المزيد من
القوات من مناطق المختلفه
وهذا هو الذي ادى يعني
افساد كل الهدن التي علمت في السابق
بالتاكيد الان المشاهد التي نشاهدها على
شاشتكم وعدد من الوسائل الاعلام
ويدعو الى الحزن بان هناك جهات تخطط لضرب
البنيه التحتيه وحرقه يعني مغدرات الامه
السودانيه وجعل حاله من
الازمه بالارض المحروقه في السودان وهذا
امر يوسف له وين عن ان هناك تدخلات وهناك
مصالح وهناك حرب اكبر من قدرات الشعب
السوداني في المرحله الحاليه وهي حرب خطه
لها بعنايه ما الذي يدفع
الجهات لحرق البنك السودان المركزي على
سبيل المثال هذا نهيج عن ضرب تدمير البنى
التحتيه في مواقع اخرى واطلاقه السجناء
هذه قضيه اصبحت واضحه ان هي حرب ضد
السودان وليست في مصلحه السودان وان الطرف
الاقوى والاقرب والعافيه ان يكون هو الطرف
المدعوم والطرف الذي يدافع الام السودانيه
وبدعني ايضا سيد خالد يعني انقل انقل هذا
التساؤل المهم
للدكتور صلاح البشير البحث السياسي ايضا
من ولايه ميريلاند ما الذي يدفع اي جهه او
اي طرف من طرفي هذه الازمه او اي حتى طرف
ثالث ان لم يكن الجيش ايضا او حتى قوات
الدعم السريع الى الاضرار بالبنك المركزي
السوداني وحرقه ايضا كما شاهدنا قبل قليل
في الصور
مرحبا بكم مرحبا بالعربيه وكل مشاهديها
ومرحبا بضيفك العزيز الاخ الاستاذ خالد
الحقيقه هذه هي سياسه الارض
المحروقه دائما
اما انا او الفوضى
وهذا واضح جدا ليست فقط من عمليه حرق
البنك المركزي السوداني وانما بكل
العمليات الخاصه بالسلب والنهب وكل
العمليات التي تحدث الان في المناطق
الصناعيه هنالك الكثير جدا جدا من المصانع
الخاصه والتي هي في ملكيه اشخاص وليست حتى
ملكيه الدوله
يتم نهبه وسرقتها ليس فقط المخزون الموجود
في المخازن فقط من مواد خام او مواد مصنعه
وانما حتى الاليات يقام بفكها وترحيلها
الى مكان اخر ثم بعد ذلك يتم حرق ما تبقى
من
المصانع وهذا يدلل على ان هنالك جهه ما
تريد ان
يعني تسيطر على الوضع او ان تكون كل ارض
السودان محروقه وهذا كما قال
ضيفك الكريم هذا عمل ضد السودان وليس لاجل
هذه الحرب وضد حتى انك اذا استطعت ان
تنتصر في هذا في هذه الحرب اللعين انك
ستحكم ستحكم من اذا انت
يعني تقوم
يعني تكسير وحركه كل مقدرات هذه الامه
المنكوبه
استاذ خالد هل دخلت فعلا السودان
سياسه الارض المحروقه برايك
نعم اسمع اليك الو تفضل كنت اسال عن سياسه
الارض المحروقه دخلت السودان فعلا هذا
السيناريو
نعم بالتاكيد انا لدي تواصل منذ ايام عدد
من ملاك المصانع في منطقه بحري وتحدثت
اليهم في عدد من المرات وان مصانعهم حرقت
ومعداتها نهبت
والمخزون الذي كان يوجد في هذه المصانع من
مواد غذائيه والسلع تم نهبه من قبل قوات
الدعم السريع العماره يعني حتى ملاك هذه
المصانع الخسران الذين كانوا يحرسون هذه
المواقع حدثوهم بان القوات التي جاءت
ونهبت وحرقت يا قوات الدعم السريعه انا
ليس لدي ما اخفي دائما اتحدث فاذا كنت انت
تريد ان تحكم الشعب السوداني وتقرب مصانع
ودور وممتلكات ومستشفيات وتطلق السجناء
كما تحدث ضيفك العزيز من من واشنطن كيف لك
ان تحكم شعب بهذا الماب منهج وهل وهل
الفكره من نشر الديمقراطيه عبر فوات
البنادق تلتقي للحرق الممتلكات الاقتصاديه
هل هناك من عقل يسوي لفكره يعني التبشير
بالديمقراطيه عبر الحريق عبر الخطابات
التي تحدث عنها قياده الدعم السريع سنجعل
الخرطوم ستتحول الى مدينه القطط والفئران
هم يفعلون ذلك نصا
وهذا خطا يعني يجب ان نتحدث بشارع العباره
الجيش السوداني ليس لديه مصلحه بحرق البنك
المركزي وليس لديه حرق مصلحه في حرقه
المصارع والديها الرسميه التي تدافع على
المنشات وتحميها ما الذي يدفع القوات
الدعم السريعه للمطارد بعدم انتشار القوات
الشرطه الاحتياطي المركزي لماذا انت تريد
ان تحدد من حركه الشرطه اذا لديك جندات
الشرطه جهاز مدني وليست جهاز حربي عسكري
للجهاز مدني يتبع لوزاره الداخليه والوزير
حتى في التقييم الهيكل الدستوريه الشرطه
يمكن ان ادخل معك في السياق الحرب اما
الحديث انا استمع الى عدد من المحدثكم في
هذه القناه اما الحديث عن الفلول والفلور
بصدر الدفاع على الفنون ولكن يعني حتى
الكلمه هي مسؤوليه اخلاقيه يجب الانسان ان
يتحدث بصريح العماره ان ما لا يجب ان نلقي
بقله تبعات هذه الحرب المدمره على اشخاص
والعاليات انا لا ادافع على بالطبع ولكن
القضيه المحوريه هي ان قوات الدعم
السريعيه التي ابتدرت هذه العرض وهي التي
احتلت المطارات وهي التي جلبت عشرات
الالاف الجنود من خارج الخرطوم وهي التي
حرقت هذه المؤسسات وهي التي اطلقت السجناء
وهي التي كل شيء فعلته لديه هناك فيديوهات
حتى حديثنا منذ ايام لديكم في هذه القناه
عن ان الاطلاق صراحه السجناء من سجن كوبر
تم عن طريق الدعم السريع استوجن واستنوا
البعض ولكن بالامس جاءت الفيديوهات واوضحت
الدعم السريع في لحظه خروج من السجن اذا
كل هذه الاعمال هناك ما يسند عمليا وتوثيق
كامل لهذه العمليات وعلى قياده الدعم
السريع الان ان تحافظ على ما تبقى لها من
من من هامش ومكان عند بعض السودانيين ان
تصدر تعليمات لقواتها
لانه تابع فقط جمله هذه الاخبار العاجله
اسفل الشاشه
للدعم السريع ايضا يقول ان كتائب من الامن
الشعبي بذي الشرطه انضمت الى الجيش قال
ايضا بان الجيش يستعد للهجوم على قوته في
حلفايه وام درمان والخرطوم ايضا كذلك جنوب
وقال بان طائرات الجيش لا تزال تحلق في
سماء الخرطوم وتنتهك الهدنه وقال بان قوته
تعرضت لهجمات من مدافع والطائرات في مناطق
متعدده من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم اذا هذه مجمل يعني التصريحات
للدعم السريع والتي يعني تاتي ربما في
سياق
زمني مع بيان الجيش السوداني قبل قليل في
سياق زمني واحد دكتور صلاح الدعم السريع
يقول بانه يستعد للهجوم على
الجيش يستعد للهجوم على قوته يقول ايضا
بان كتائب الامن او كتائب من الامن الشعبي
بذيء الشرطه انضمت الى الجيش ما الذي يعني
هذا اولا
هذا بحث عن
اسباب خارجيه انت
ابتدرت هذه الحرب كنت تظن انك تستطيع ان
تضع الناس امام واحد من خمس سيناريوهات
اما ان تحدث انقلاب الناجحا او ان تحدث
حاله حوسيه او ان سيطرتك على منطقه
الخرطوم فقط او ان تحدث حاله ليبيه
بان يكون لديك
مطار ويكون لديك
عاصمه خاصه كما فعلت كما كانت المحاوله في
مروي او ان انك تريد ان تخلق فوضى غير
خلاقه
تستهلك من خلالها باطاله امد الحرب
قوه الجيش وقوه المجتمع المدني ككل وقوه
المواطن السوداني وبالتالي تجلس في موقف
تفاوضى افضل لذلك كل هذه
السيناريوهات المطروحه لم تعد الان موجوده
لان الجيش وقف ضد هذا التحرك بغض النظر عن
كل ما يقوله البعض من ان هنالك مجموعه من
الفلول او الاسلامويين على راس هذا الجيش
وهي التي تحركه الجيش مؤسسه
دستوريه الجيش مؤسسه وطنيه الجيش
بالدستور هو الذي يحق له ان
يمتلك العنف ويمتلك القدره على حمايه
البلد حينما تكون اذا
لا يمكن لمجرد ان هنالك هدنه تقول انك انت
خلال هذه الهدنه تحرك الياتك كما تشاء ثم
تمنع الاخرين من فعل ذلك ساعود اليكما من
جديد ضيف الدكتور صلاح البشير وايضا كذلك
الاستاذ خالد العيسر اذا مشاهدينا في ذات
الملف حضر رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق
عبد الله حمدوك من ان النزاع في السودان
قد يتفاقم الى احدى اسوا الحروب الاهليه
في العالم في حال لم يتم وضعها الدله
واضاف انه في حال وصول السودان الى نقطه
حرب اهليه حقيقيه فان سوريا واليمن وليبيا
ستكون مجرد مبارزات صغيره معتبرا ان ذلك
سيشكل كابوسا للعالم وستكون له تداعيات
كبيره وراى كذلك حمدوك ان النزاع الحالي
عباره عن حرب لا معنى لها بين جيشين مؤكدا
ان لا احدا سيخرج منها منتصرا ولهذا السبب
يجب ان تتوقف
اكد المسؤول الاعلامي للهلالي الاحمر
السوداني للعربيه ان العمل داخل
المستشفيات يجري بامكانيات محدوده جدا
وهناك حاجه ماسه لوصول المساعدات من
الخارج
المؤسسات بتدبر يعني الوضع الذاتي وببعض
المساعدات من بعض الجهات حتى المنظمات
القاسمه بما موجود عندها من مخزون ثابت
ومنظم المنظمات بما فيها حتى الهلال
الاحمر السوداني وغيرها كل المنظمات
المعنيه بمساعده لمساعدات الانسانيه
وبتعمل في القطاع الصحي كوضع طبيعي كجاري
جارب العمل الانساني بكرية مخزون طبيعي
لكن مخزون الحالات العاديه للحالات
الطارئه في الوضع العادي يعني فدلوقتي
بتدبر الاضافه الى
مساهمات
الاطباء لتشكيلاتهم المختلفه بهيئات
بنقابات
بتنظيمهم الحالي لمجابهه الواقع من
ومن الخاص وكذا لكن عشان نبدا نجابها
الموجوده دي لازم تيجي مساعدات من الخارج
[موسيقى]
حاليا الادويه
اللي خلصت عندنا تماما او على وشك يا
ادويه الضغط
[موسيقى]
الاحداث الدو حقك تنسانين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن ولدها تفتش وما خلوه
اي استفدج عشان تقول
[موسيقى]
اذا يزداد الضغط على القطاع الصحي في
السودان حتى اصبح الحديث عن انهيار النظام
الصحي امرا غير مستبعد
من سيء الى اسوا انهيار النظام الصحي في
السودان بات وشيكا في كل يوم يزداد عدد
المرافق الصحيه التي تخرج عن الخدمه
الواحده تلو الاخرى جراء القصف او نقص
المعدات والمستلزمات الطبيه او بسبب غياب
الكوادر الطبيه وضع اذا استمر وبنفس
الوتيره سيهدد وقريبا بالاغلاق التام
لكافه المرافق الصحيه الرسميه في ظل تواصل
العمليات العسكريه وفقا لنقابه الاطباء
السودانيه لكن الذي اريد ان اؤكده ان
هنالك ليس هنالك ضمانات للممرات الامنه
فهناك ما يحدث في الجنينه انما هي مبدا
انسانيه مجزره بشريه مخالب لكل
القوانين الدوليه غياب الممره كذلك خلال
الهدنه التي يتم خرقها في كل مره سبب
رئيسي لعزل هذه المرافق الحيويه وجعلها
مكانا خطيرا لا يمكن الوصول اليه مع
السباحه واستهداف كل من طرفي نزاعلها لا
يقتصر انهيار النظام الصحي فقط على مناطق
الاشتباكات بالخرطوم بل يمتد الى جميع
الاقاليم التي تاثرت بانقطاع الامداد
الدوائي ونزوح الاطباء خارج البلاد
الخرطوم الجثث عددها كبيره جدا واحد اثنين
اتساع للرقعه الجغرافيه بتاعه ولايه
الخرطوم يعني ان احنا لو عايزين نغطي
ولايه الخرطوم كلها بمحليات السبعه هي هي
حاجه ضخمه جدا
ارتفاع اعداد المصابين تسبب ايضا بالضغط
على القطاع الصحي واستنزاف الموارد
الموجوده
حيث شهدت مدينه كسلا الواقعه في اقصى
الشرق والتي تبعد قرابه 600 كم عن الخرطوم
نقصا حدا في اسطوانات الاكسجين فضلا عن
انعدام اكياس الدم بانحاء الولايه
كالرمحناوي العربيه
عود مره اخرى الى الكاتب الصحفي خالد
الاعسر وايضا الى ضيفي الدكتور صلاح بشير
من ولايه مريلاند مرحبا بكم معي مره اخرى
في هذه الساعه استاذ خالد دعني ابدا معك
بما حذر منه رئيس الوزراء السابق عبد الله
يعني تفاقم الوضع في السودان ان وصل الى
الحرب الاهليه لماذا يعتبر وصول السودان
الى هذه النقطه انحدث ستكون يعني نماذج
ليبيا وسوريا واليمن مبارازات صغيره امام
السودان
انا في تقديري اختلف مع الاخ الدكتور عبد
الله حمدوك في هذه الرؤيه
بالتاكيد الشعب السوداني محصن محصن وفق
الاراده الشعبيه والتلاحم الوجداني الكبير
الذي
بانه ووضح جليا بانه يشكل حصن متين ومنيع
لعدم انجرافه البلاد في دخول حرب اهليه
والشاهد ان كل مدير السودان بلا استثناء
خرجت الى القيادات العامه للقوات المسلحه
في مواقعها لم نشهد الا تضافر بين كل
ابناء القبائل بمختلف لهجاتهم
وقبائلهم هذا الحديث انا بختلف معه تماما
ان السودانيون يدركون تمام الادراك ان هذه
الحرب هي حرب الامه السودانيه
ضد السودان ايا كانت خلفياتهم القبليه بل
شاهدنا التحديد للقبائل في كل السودان
ودعوه رجالات القبائل
وعمد القبائل الى ابناءهم في القوات في
القوات الدعم لكي يصلخوا همم لا يوجد مبرر
لم تنزلقه البلاد في حرب اهليه هي تكون
الاكبر بالعكس انا ارى ان الشعب السوداني
متوحد وجدانيا خلف قوات الشعب المسلحه
التي هي القوات المسلحه اليوم وبالتالي
حتى الخلافات التي برزت هنا او هناك في
دارفور هي خلافات متجزره منذ ستينات
مرمى الماضي
وبالتالي للجميع
وفي القرارات الصادره عن مجلس الامن
القضايا معلومه ومعروفه هي نزاعات بين
رعاه ومزارعين تطورت الى شكل من اشكال
التدخلات السياسيه وضع حد لها في عدد من
المحاولات التي تمت باتفاقها السلام
وشراكه والان الموقف يحمد لغات الحركات
الموقعه على سلام جوبا لوم التحيه
والتقدير والتجله لقد قاموا بدور وطني
كبير بدخوله في محاوله فض النزاعات
القبليه التي هي والنزاعات قديمه ووقف
عمليات النهضه في مناطق ملتهبه في دارفور
ليس فقط منذ 15 ابريل الجاري او الماضي
وانما منذ سنوات طويله للوراء بالتالي انا
لا اعتقد ان الشعب السوداني يمكن ان يدخل
في حرب اهليه بسبب هذه الفتنه التي وردته
عبر مخالب داخليه وجلدات خارجيه وانا
متاكد ان الشعب السوداني تم متحصن تماما
وبمختلف انتماءاته السياسيه
ومناطقه ولغات ولهجات وقبائل متوحد خلف
هذه القوات المسلحه
هذه المعرفه يجب ان يصطفي جميع خلف القوات
المسلحه بل صرح لديكم هنا في هذه القناه
الامين العام المتحده وذكر نصا للشعب
السوداني في عدد من المناطق والمدن يستقبل
المواطنين الذين خرجوا من الخرطوم
لاشخاص قدموا من الخرطوم ومناطق حصلت فيها
نزاعات ولا يعلمون حتى من هم يكفي انهم
السوداني هناك صيوانات ضربت
فيه شمس وفي مدن اخرى في كردي ينتظر عوده
واضح لا
يوجد دكتور خالد تشائم حمدوكال يعكس واقع
المشهد السوداني برايك
عفوا
على اعتبار يعني امرين مهمين انا اتفق مع
الاستاذ خالد العيسر في كل ما قاله بان
الشعب السوداني الذي قدم ثوره سلميه لاربع
سنوات
محصن بعض شيء من الدخول في اتون حرب اهليه
لكن مشكله هذه الحرب التي
تدار اليوم ان هنالك ما وراء اكمتها من
مؤسسات اقليميه بشكل عام هذه المؤسسات
الاقليميه تعمل على ابتلاع السودان
بكاملها
وعلى هذا الاساس يمكن ان تنجر
بواسطه مال الحروب
الى مواقف لا يحسد الناس او لا يقصد
السودان عليها ونجد انفسنا اما في حرب كما
قال الدكتور
حمدوك ربما تطال اكثر من السودان
او في اتون حرب اهليه طويله المدى
الغرض منها الفوضى العارمه واستهلاك كل
مقدرات هذه الامه التي اعمل ان
تعطيها الشواهد النصر سريعه باذن الله
اشكركم جزيل الشكر من ولايه ميريلاند
الامريكيه الباحث السياسي الدكتور صلاح
البشير وايضا الكاتب الصحفي خالد الاعاسر
التحق بنا من لندن شكرا جزيلا لكما
اذا تستمروا عمليات نزوح السودانيين
الفرين من الاشتباكات الى الحدود المصريه
وبينما تقلصت اعداد القادمين الى معبر
ارجين زادت نسبه الوافدين عبر منفذ قسطل
ومنه تمر الحافلات الواصله عبر عباره او
عبر عباره نحو مدينه ابو سمبل
[موسيقى]
هكذا تبدو بوابه الخروج من معبر ارجين
تقلص كبير في اعداد القادمين من السودان
وتقلص ايضا في اعداد الحافلات التي
تنتظرهم منذ اكثر من اسبوعين
[موسيقى]
حولهم بقى على المعبر الثاني اللي هو
النهرده بس وحولوا الاتوبيسات وحولوا
الناس كلها على هناك النهارده الحركه
خفيفه قد تكون الحركه من قصه طبعا الجانب
الاشتباكات بس احنا ما نعرفش اي حاجه ايه
اللي حاصل في الجانب السوداني
اصحاب سيارات نقل البضائع الكبيره سينجحون
اخيرا في المرور من معبر ارجين والدخول
الى الاراضي السودانيه بعد توقف دام اكثر
من اسبوعين
[موسيقى]
خرجت اخيرا من معبر ارجين من يستقلون هذه
الحافله يشعرون بالارهاق وتحدثوا معنا على
معلومه من خلال هذه الرحله الطويله ده لكل
الناس تتجه لحلفه فاحنا كنا اخر بس جاي
على ارجينا
ظن المعبر زحمه شديده في غريب 30 باص
والمعبر زحمه شديد لكن احنا شنو
خشينا بس عملنا الاجراءات ولقينا خلينا
على بعضنا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وسواء بري او مينائي ابو سمبل النيلي فان
الرحله تكتمل اخيرا بالوصول الى الحدود
المصريه احمد عثمان لقناتي العربيه والحدث
من ميناء ابو سمبل النيلي
عدد من انصار نظام الرئيس المعزول عمر
البشير توعدوا بنشر الفوضى في السودان من
اجل قطع الطريق امام اي اتفاق تتاسس
بموجبه حكومه مدنيه والتي ستقطع الطريق
امام عودتهم للحكم مجددا قيادات اخوانيه
في النظام البشير شنت حمله تحريض واسعه
لاشعال الحرب وعدم تحقيق انتقال نحو حكومه
مدنيه
على ركام الحرب الجاريه في السودان انصار
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير يبحثون عن موطئ
قدم فالحرب فرصتهم الوحيده وستحدد مصيرهم
انصار البشير وحزب المؤتمر الوطني
الاخواني توعدوا بنشر الفوضى في البلاد
قطعا للطريق امام اي اتفاق تتاسس بموجبه
حكومه مدنيه فالحكومه المدنيه الديمقراطيه
تعني بالاساس عدم عودتهم للحكم مجددا
بعدما قادوا البلاد لمده 30 عاما بقبضه من
حديد
هؤلاء شنوا حمله تحريض واسعه لاشعال الحرب
وما ان اشتعلت حتى ظلوا يطالبون
باستمرارها بل وصل الامر باحد خطبائهم لحد
اصدار فتوى بقتل المدنيين المعارضين
لتواصل الاشتباكات فان بعض الناس لا لا
يكف شره الا بان يقطع دابره وان يقتل لانه
مرض على الخيانه والنفاق خاصه انا اقول
ليس المقاتلين فقط يعني هناك من الاحزاب
العميله من كان ينفخ في نار هذه الحرب
ويهدد بها الحمله استهلها القيادي الحاج
ادم يوسف محرضا انصار حزبه اذ حثهم على
مواجهه القوى المؤيده للحكم المدني
اما اما انتخابات او مداخلات احسن مداخل
كبار وصغار تمشي تقع في الشارع ما كبير
امشي واقع
القيادي في الحركه والواليه السابق الذي
اشتهر بمواقفه المتطرفه انس عمر وصف
الحكومه المدنيه الانتقاليه بالفاشله
كاشفا عن دورهم في اسقاطها ومهددا في
الوقت ذاته باسقاط اي حكومه مدنيه
[موسيقى]
الحكومه ما دارنا خرج من عنا شريعه الله
اما نائب البشير الاسبق ابراهيم محمود فقد
وجه انصار حزبه بالاستعداد للنزول الى
الميدان في حال توقيع الاتفاق السياسي
النهائي نحن نقول الان استعدوا اخواني
هذا الاتفاق لوالن كل الشعب السوداني لازم
يكون في الميدان
انصار حزب المؤتمر الوطني الذي تزعمه
البشير رفعوا شعارا جديدا يقوم على تخوين
كل من ينادي بوقف الحرب حمله الترهيب
والتخوين والتشويه والتخويف هذه تستهدف
قاده القوى المدنيه التي اسقطت نظام
البشير بالثوره الشعبيه في ربيع العام
انصار البشير نشطوا بوعيده توقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي حمله تحريض ضخمه ضد هذا الاتفاق
الذي يقضي بتسليم السلطه للمدنيين
التحليلات والوقائع تشير الى ان جماعه
الاخوان وانصار البشير يعتبرون الحرب
الدائره معركتهم الاخيره يلقون فيها بكل
اسلحتهم الامر الذي يجعل سيناريو الحرب
الوحيد المتاحه امام بقائهم فلا خيار اخر
لهم في مواجهه الرفض الشعبي الواسع
لعودتهم الى الحكم من جديد
ما يحدث في السودان حربا بين جنرالين هناك
اطراف لعبت دورا في تصعيد المواجهه
وتستفيد من هذه الازمه
من اس ينضم الينا الاكاديمي والباحث
السياسي الشافعي محمد عثمان ومن الخرطوم
بحري انضم الينا الصحفي محمد اسحاق عثمان
ابدا من السيده الشفيع محمد عثمان
لاسالك عن نظام الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير
اين هو من جمله كل ما يحدث اليوم في
السودان وما هو مدى تورده فيما يحدث
العزيز اخي العزيز في الواقع هذه هي
التركه الثقيله التي احدثها نظام الثلاثين
من يونيو
سقط النظام لكن ترك ترك خلفه تركه مثقله
من الفشل ومن الفساد ومن الاشكالات
الهيكليه في الدوله السودانيه احد ملامح
الاشكالات الهيكليه في الدوله السودانيه
هي قوات الدعم السريع
يقول ان هؤلاء
النظام البشير ومن لف لفه يتحملون
المسؤوليه الاولى لما قالت اليه الامور
الان في السودان وهما الان يتحملون
المسؤوليه الاولى في تعقيدات التحول
الديمقراطي في تعقيدات التحول نحو دوله
القانون والعداله الدوله التي مهرت بدماء
زكيه من شباب واطفال يافعين من اجل تحقيق
وطن من اجل استعاده وطن كان ماثورا تحت
هذه التقمه الحاكمه لثلاثين عاما حتى الان
يعني هم
بدفعهم
وتشجيعهم لهذه الحرب عقدوا حتى من المشهد
السياسي الاداره الامريكيه الان انا متابع
الى الى تطورات موقف الاداره الامريكيه
اتجاه اتجاه مجاجر الان من السودان
الاداره الامريكيه الان قبل عطله نهايه
هذا الاسبوع رشح رشح منحى جديد في تعاطيها
مع شان السودان بسبب هؤلاء الفلول الان هم
يتحدثون عن ما اسموه به هم في الاساس
كانوا داعمين للجيش السوداني طيب لكن الان
هم يعني وصلوا لاتجاه جديد رشح خلال عطله
هذه الاسبوع اسمه ما اسمه بتوازن القوه
بمعنى انهم لا يسمحون لاي طرف ان ينتصر
على الثاني الذي يعني هذا سيد الشفيع هذا
يعني الاداره الامريكيه قطاع عريض خصوصا
الاجهزه الامنيه انهم غير واثقون من ان
هذا الجيش هو الجيش وطني هم يعلمون علم
اليقين ان هذا الجيش في غياته مختطف من
فنون النظام السابق ويعتمر بامر
الوطني ويعتمر بعمر الحركه الاسلاميه وهذا
مصدر تخوف بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه من
عوده النظام السابق لذلك هم الان غيروا من
تكتيكاتهم للوصول الى سيقه
سيقه اسموها توازن الرعبه حيث لا يسمح لاي
طرف ان ينهزم فيها ان ينتصر في هذه
المعركه الدائره الان ما بين الدعم السريع
الجيش السوداني
لكن دعني انت
الجيش السوداني به كثير من الاشكالات وانا
ليس دائما لاي من طرفي الصرع هنالك
اشكالات هيكليه في الجيش السوداني هنالك
اخطاء ارتكبت من قبل الجيش السوداني واكبر
هذه الاخطاء هو تعمل سريع
نفدا الان قبل 15 يوم كانوا داعمين الان
اصبحوا ابن قير شرعي بالنسبه له هذه سيدي
هذه اخطاء للجيش السوداني واتمنى ان هذه
الاخطاء
واول مره الجيش السوداني يؤد وظيفه وطنيه
حقيقيه بحيث انه يصحح خطره ويتحلى هذا
الصراع عسكريا هذا الصراع يا عزيزي صراع
عسكري لا يحل سياسيا هذا الصراع لا يقبل
القسمه الا على واحد هذا الصراع لا يقبل
القسمه على اثنين يا سيدي
الشفيع لكن دعني انتقل ايضا الى الخرطوم
بحري والى الصحه في محمد اسحاق عثمان
مرحبا بك معي من جديد اريد السؤال اولا عن
عمليات التنشيط في منطقه حلفايه
بالخرطوم بحري ما هي الاهميه لهذه المنطقه
اولا وما الذي جرى من عمليات تمشيط في
حلفايه منذ الصباح سيد محمد
نعم مرحبا نايف والان
اقول بان الهدوء والحذر لا زال يسيطر على
المكان بعد هذه العمليات الشركه والمعاركه
التي تابعناها منذ عصر الامس منطقه
الحلفايه تقع شمال مدينه الخرطوم بحرين
وهذا الجسر الذي تعرف فيه المعارك ويعتبر
جسر حيوي يربط ما بين الخرطومه بحري
ومدينه ام درمان هذه المنطقه اذا
اجتها معارك الشركه جدا ما بين الجيش وما
بين الجيش وتدعم السريع ربما اثر القوات
الدعم السريعه التمركز في هذا الجسم
الحلفاء محاوله السيطره عليه لقضاء
الامداد وقضى هذه المنطقه اقصى شمال بحري
عملي من ناحيه عملياتيه
للسيطره بعد ذلك على العوده من جديد لهذا
الجيني خصوصا وان هذا الطريق ايضا طريق
يربط ما بين
الخرطوم او لايه نهر النيل ايضا هو طريق
حيوي امتداد شارع المعونه الذي يمر من عند
جسر الحلفايه ولكن نايف في هذه اللحظات
الحظ مرور هذه الدوريات الشرطيه الشرطه
كانت قد نزلت بالامس وقد تم الاعلان بانها
سيتم دعمها التدريجيا وقت الاحتياطي
المركزي الان تجوب الشوارع هنا على الاقل
في مدينه الخرطوم بحري من خلال حديث راشع
عبر بعض المصادر استطاعت هذه القوات من
خلال فتره الليل وحتى هذه اللحظه القاء
الخط اكثر من 400 من هؤلاء المتخلفين
الذين خرجوا من السجون في الفتره الاخيره
وتسببوا في الرعب ومساله السلب والنهب
التي عانت منها ولايه الخرطوم بصوره عامه
الان هذه القوات كما علمنا اعاده الانتشار
والتبركل في المناطق الرئيسيه حول البنوك
والمستشفيات ومواقع الخدمه التي تقدم
للمواطنين المواطنين الان الحظ بانهم بدات
حاره نسبيه الان في الخروج بعض الاسواق
بدات في مزاوله عملها
ربما بان المواطنين بعد مشاهدتهم بقوات
الشرطه قوات الاحتياطي المركزي التي
يخبرونها جيدا واحده من القوات التي توصف
بانها هو ضاربه وشريفه جدا في التعامل
تجاه مسائل الفوضى والتخريب الان ربما خلق
ذلك في نفوسهم جزءا كبيرا من الاطمئنان
والطوبانيين خرجوا الان نايف الى الشوارع
لقضاء مستلزماته بعض الاسر تعلم بان
الفتره قد صارت من خلال هذه المعارك التي
تنشف فجاه يصعبون سريع لقضاء حاجياتهم
والاتفاق بما يمكن انقهم للايام القادمه
عد مره اخرى الى السيد الشفيع يعني قبل
قليل ان تتحدثت عن بعض الاشكالات التي
تحيط بالجيش
السوداني في هذه الفتره في وقت سابق ذكر
حميدتي وبما اننا يعني تحدثنا واياك بعد
التقرير الذي يعني يتحدث عن نظام الرئيس
المعزول البشير ويعني كيف القى هذا النظام
بظلاله على احداث السودان اليوم حمتي ذكر
في وقت سابق بان البرهان يحيط به فلول من
النظام السابق ويتحدثون عن القيادات في
الجيش السوداني برايك هل هذه وحده من
الاشكالات التي تحيط فعلا بالجيش السوداني
كان هذا صحيحا
هذه وحده واحده من الاشكالات لكنها ليست
المشكله الوحيده بواقع ان المؤسسه
العسكريه السودانيه مؤسسه منهكه بحروب
عباسيه وهذا الجيش على الدوام لم يحارب
الا شعبي في حرب عبسيه منذ العام 1955
وضعت اوزارها باتفاقيه اديس ابابا في
العام 1972 ثم اندلعت مجددا في العام 1983
وضعت اوزارها باتفاقيه السلام الشامل في
2005 وقبل ان توضع اوزاره اندلعت حرب
جديده في دارفور في العمل 2001 هذا جيشهم
واكثر من انكته الحروب العباسيه
في اغتيال شعبه مواطنيه هذا الشعب تعرض
هذا الجيش تعرض لادلجه بمعنى ان الانتمال
هذه المؤسسه طوال الثلاثين عاما كان شعاره
الاساسي الولاه قبل الاداب عليك ان تقسم
الول لتنظيم الحركه الاسلاميه
قبل الانضمام لهذا الجيش احب اشكالات هذه
المؤسسه العسكريه انها ليست مؤسسه
غيوميه ولا وليست لها اهداف وطنيه حقيقيه
تم اختطاف هذه المؤسسه منذ العام 1989
لصالح الجهه احدثت بها تخريب منهجي والدعم
السريع هو مؤشر اضافي على تخريب هذه
المؤسسه لكن على الرغم من ما تعرضت له هذه
المؤسسه نحن ندعو الى الحفاظ عليها وندعو
الى اعاده هيكلتها وفقر علميه منهجيه في
سوابق مره بها اغلب الجيوش في العالم
سيد الشفيع ابقى معي لكن انتقل ايضا الى
الخرطوم بحري مره اخرى للصحفي محمد اسحاق
كنت تتحدث عن عوده الحياه بشكل تدريجي الى
الخرطوم
بحري يعني كيف يمكن ان تنقل لنا ما شاهدته
من عوده الحياه في اي المناطق ايضا عاده
وكذلك اي الاسواق والمؤسسات الحيويه التي
عادت الى العمل مره اخرى
نعم لعلي في هذه اللحظات الحظ هذه
الحافلات التي تستقل في عمليه
النزوح والخروج خارج ولايه الخرطوم هذه
الحافلات الان عادت وتمركزت امام جسر
الحلفايه
هذه الحافلات كانت غابت في الفتره الماضيه
لعدها كما ذكرت من قبل تتمركز كانت في
موقف محدد لها في منطقه شمبات في الخرطوم
بحري ولكن نسبه للتضرر هذا المكان والقص
الذي تبع السوق المركزي بحري انتقلت الى
جسر الحلفايه ولكن نسبه العمليات والمعارك
الذي دارت بهذا الجسر يوم امس وقبله اختفت
هذه الحافلات الان
قد عادت من جديد وهذا دليل عافيه على ان
المنطقه تعاني من بعض الهدوء النسبيه ايضا
هناك واحد من الاسواق المعروفه هنا
يعرفونها اهل هذه المنطقه مناطق الدروشاب
والحلفايه سوق الاحد هذا السوق اختفى
ولكنه عاد الان بصوره يمكن ان اقول بانها
يعني يمكن ان تقارب او نسبه 60 او 70%
الان المحال الصيدليات الاحظها بعد ان
اختفت بدات تعود للخدمه من جديد هذه دلاله
وافيه بان هذا او هذه
القوات الشرفيه التي تم الدفع بها الى
الميدان ربما احدثت اختراقا واضحا في
احداث نوع من الطمانينه كما ذكرت قبل قليل
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الخرطوم بحري الصحه
في محمد اسحاق عثمان وكذلك ضيفي الباحث
والبحث السياسي والاكاديمي محمد عثمان من
اوستن
[موسيقى]
بين عزم الجيش السوداني على حسم المعركه
واصرار قوات الدعم السريع على الصمود
الحرب تتواصل في السودان الذي تحول لبقعه
جغرافيه ساخنه بالرغم من تزايد وتيره
المساعي الدوليه التي تطالب المكونين
العسكريين بضروره ايجاد حل سلمي ينهي
الصراع
الصراع في السودان يتواصل لينذر بتحول
البلاد لبؤره توتر اقليمي وجبهه قتال قد
تمتد لدول الجوار توتر صاحبته دعوه دوليه
واقليميه الى ضروره نزع فتيل الازمه
والالتزام بمسار الهدنه واعاده البلاد
لاكمال المسار الديمقراطي المتعثر منذ
سنوات طويله الامم المتحده لن تتخلى عن
السودان هذا ما اكده امينه العام انطونيو
غوتيريش الذي دعا الجيش وقوات الدعم
لتغليب لغه الحوار وانهاء الصراع الذي يجب
ان يكون مرتبطا بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار
السودان الامم المتحده لن تتخلى عن
السودان وستفعل كل ما بوسعها لتوفير
الظروف الامنيه من اجل تقديم الدعم
الانساني للشعب السوداني ومن نيويورك ايضا
اكدت مندوبه بريطانيا في الامم المتحده ان
تهدف للحصول على دعم مجلس الامن لمقترحات
الاتحاد الافريقي فيما يخص الوضع الحالي
في السودان الذي تحول لبقعه جغرافيه ساخنه
هو الحصول على الدعم الكامل من مجلس الامن
لمقترحات ايجاد للتقدم نحو وقف اطلاق نار
ومن ثم العوده للعمليه السياسيه
التطورات الحاصله دفعت باطراف دوليه
واقليميه وعربيه لطرح مبادرات تهدئه بين
الطرفين والتوسط لاتفاق على وقف اطلاق
النار لتعبيد الطريق امام حكومه مدنيه حيث
ان المبعوث الاممي للسودان اشار الى ان
طرفي الصراع في السودان منفتحان على
الحوار الدمار وفق مراقبين فان انقاذ
البلاد من الفوضى والدمار وتشكيل حكومه
تكنوقراط تضمن الخروج من الازمه الحاليه
يتطلب تجديد الرياده الدبلوماسيه من طرف
المجموعه الدوليه ومعاقبه الاطراف التي
تسببت في زعزعه استقرار السودان
[موسيقى]
جوله على ابرز الاخبار الدوليه قال متحدث
باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوات موسكو
قصفت موقع القياده والمراقبه للطائرات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه قرب منطقه خرسون
والحقت وحدات المدفعيه اضرارا بنيرانها
بموقع القياده والمراقبه ومركز التحكم
للطائرات بدون الطيار التابعه للواء 124
من قوه الدفاع الاقليمي التابعه
مضيفا ان قوات موسكو دمرت مستودعه تخزين
الذخيره والمعدات قرب المدينه الساحليه
جنوب البلاد موضحا ان القصف الروسي اسفر
عن مقتر 30 شخصا من صفوف القوات
الاوكرانيه وسحق اكثر من 10 مركبات قتاليه
مصفحه
من جهته قلل المتحدث باسم القوات
الاوكرانيه
ان بلاده لا تزال تسيطر على طريق امداد
هام مؤذن الى باخموت مؤكده لوسائل اعلام
محليه ان الوضع في باقمت لا يزال صعبا
بسبب محاولات القوات الروسيه السيطره على
طريق الحياه المؤدي للمدينه الا ان قوات
بلاده لن تسمح للروس بقطع الخدمات
اللوجستيه للجيش الاوكراني
قتل مدنيان روسيان نتيجه قصف اوكراني
استهدف احدى قرى مقاطعه بريانسك الروسيه
بحسب حاكم المقاطعه كما اشار حاكم بريانسك
الى تدمير مبنى سكني وتضرر منزلين نتيجه
القصف الاوكراني
نددت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه بما وصفته
بالانتهاك الصارخ لاتفاقيه فينا للعلاقات
الدبلوماسيه وبالعمل العدائي من السلطات
البولنديه وذلك بعد مصادره مبنى مدرسه
روسيه تابعه لسفرتها في وارسو وحضرت
الخارجيه الروسيه من ان هذا العمل خارج
اطار التواصل الحضاري بين الدول وانه لن
يبقى دون رد فعل وعواقب قاسيه على السلطات
البولنديه والمصالح البولنديه في روسيا
فرقت شرطه الاسرائيليه الاحتجاج الاسبوعي
واعتقلت عددا من المتظاهرين واندلعت
مناوشات بين الطرفين بعد انتهاء الاحتجاج
الذي حضره عشرات الالاف من الاسرائيليين
ضد خطط حكومه رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو لفرض قيود على القضاء الذي يرون
انه يمثل تهديدا وجوديا للديمقراطي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لعميد لدين اتنسيات بيته مش خيوط
[موسيقى]
اغلقت تركيا مجالها الجوي امام طائرات
شركه فلايوان ارمينيا دون سابقي انذار حسب
ما ذكرت وكاله ارمين للانباء عن رئيس مجلس
اداره الشركه وقال ارام اننيان رئيس مجلس
اداره الشركه الارمينيه انه لاسباب غير
مفهومه ودون اي مبرر واضح الغط سلطات
الطيران التركيه تصريحا كانت قد منحته
لشركه فلايوان ارمينيا لتسيير رحلات الى
اوروبا عبر المجال الجوي التركي واشار
انينيا الى ان قرار السلطات التركيه
المفاجئ تسبب في وضع غير مريح لشركه
فلايوان ارمينيا وركابها
يتوجه اكثر من 16 مليون ناخب اوزباكي الى
صناديق الاقتراع اليوم للادلاء باصواتهم
في الاستفتاء الجديد على الدستور الذي
ينتظر ان يصوغ مستقبل البلاد خلال المرحله
المقبله ويتضمن مشروع الدستور الجديد بندا
يرفع فتره ولايه رئيس اوزباكستان من خمس
الى سبع سنوات وبندا اخرا يسمح بانتخاب
الرئيس الحالي شوكه
للمره الثالثه بهذا المنصب ما سيتيح له
البقاء في السلطه حتى 2040
اعلنت قوات قفر السواحل في تونس انتشال
نحو 210 من الجثث لمهاجرين خلال اقل من
اسبوعين وذلك بعد ان جرفتها الامواج على
الساحل الاوسط للبلدي في خضم زياده مستمره
في الهجره وتشير الفحوص الاوليه للجثث الى
ان المهاجرين من منطقه افريقيا جنوب
الصحراء
اكد القيادي في حركه طالبان محمد سهيل
شاهين ان اي اجتماع بشان افغانستان دون
مشاركه حكومه تصريف الاعمال الافغانيه
الحاليه لن يساعد في حل المشكلات بل
سيعقدها وجاءت تصريحات رئيس المكتب
السياسي للحركه في العاصمه القطريه الدوحه
قبيل الاجتماع اممي دولي مرتقب بشان
افغانستان في الدوحه لا تشاركوا فيه
طالبان واضاف شاهين ان من حق حكومه تصريف
الاعمال الافغانيه الحاليه ان يسمع صوتها
في الاجتماعات والمنتديات المتعلقه بحل
القضايا ذات الصله في افغانستان
نقلت وكاله يونهاب للانباء في كوريا
الجنوبيه عن وسائل اعلام في كوريا
الشماليه ان بيون جينغ تتعهد بتعزيز الردع
العسكري ردا على اعلان واشنطن زياده
التطبيق العملي للردع الموسع لكوريا
الشماليه معتبره ما تقدمه الولايات
المتحده هو نتاج او نتاج نموذج للسياسات
العدائيه تجاه كوريا الشماليه مشيره ان
بيونغيانج ستعزز ردعها العسكري الذي
يتناسب مع المخاطر الامنيه التي تواجهها
الولايات المتحده الصين بوقف ما وصفته
بالسلوك الاستفزازي وغير الامن في بحر
الصين الجنوبي المتنازعي عليه التحذير
الامريكي صدر عقب ان اقتربت سفينه تابعه
لخفر السواحل الصينيه مؤخرا من سفينه
دوريه فلبينيه اكد ان يتسبب في تصادمهم
وتعمل المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
بمضايقه وترهيب السفن الفلبينيه في
المنطقه
وافقت مجموعه الدول السبع على تعزيز
الاستخدام المسؤول الذكاء الاصطناعي في
اطار سعيه لتسخير التقنيات المتطوره مثل
روبوتات شات
مخاوفه تتعلق بالخصوصيه ومخاطر اساءات
استخدامهم واكد وزراء التكنولوجيا من
اليابان والولايات المتحده ودول اوروبيه
عقب اجتماعهم في شرق اليابان على الحاجه
الى اليه دوليه لتعزيز التدفق الحر
للبيانات الموثوقه عبر الحدود الوطنيه
اعلن رجل الاعمال الملياردير ايلون ماسك
عن خطه لمنصه تويتر تسمح لناشيري الوسائل
الاعلاميه بتقاضي بدل من المستخدمين على
اساس قراءه كل مقاله على حده وبنقره واحده
وقال ماسك الخطه ستمكن المستخدمين الذين
لم يشتركوا شهريا بدفع بدل اعلى مقابل
قراءه كل مقاله بشكل عابر وان الامر سيشكل
مكسبا رئيسيا للمؤسسات الاعلاميه والجمهور
طلب اعصار قوي منطقه
الامريكيه بحسب ما اعلنت هيئه الارصاد
الجويه الوطنيه في البلاد وادى الطقس
القاسي الى قلب السيارات وتحطم النوافل
والاشجار اوضحت السلطات انه لم يتم
الابلاغ عن وقوع اي اصابات لكنها طلبت من
السكان الحد من نشاطهم الخارجي
والابتعاد ايضا عن خطوط الكهرباء
المتساقطه خاصه مع توقعات
مع توقعات ترجح ان اعصارا او اثنين
سيتبعان هذه العاصفه
اوسط سلطاته في كولومبيا سكان بلدات قريبه
من كان نشط يصدر هديرا باخلائها تحسبا
لثوران محتمل وقال مكتب اداره الكوارث انه
يعتزم اخلاء المناطق الماهوله التي تقع
على بعد 15 كيلو مترا من الفوهه الرئيسيه
لبركان نيفادو
الذي يتكون من ثلاث فوهات في جبال في جبال
الانديز الكولومبيه
نهايه هذه الساعه الاخباريه نعود لاستكمال
على راس الساعه مع زميل ابراهيم بدري اليك
ابراهيم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات